hello everyone this here is probably one
of the more disturbing games you will
ever see in your life it was played in
the amber tournament in 1993 now
the amber tournament some of you might
have heard it heard of it they have a
rapid tournament and the blind fall
tournament in the 1992 it was the first
amber tournament they only had a rapid
section and mostly one to go on this
tournament this game it's from the 1993
amber tournament and although I couldn't
confirm is the game from the rapid
section or from the blindfold section
I'm sure you'll agree after you see the
game it's definitely from the blindfold
section now the the rapid section was
won by a noob amid avoid the voyage and
the rapid the blindfold section was won
by Vishwanathan Anand and anatoly karpov
here they shared first place but this
here game unit polgár has the white
pieces against a former world champion
Anatoly Karpov and this is just
disturbing so let's see this game we
have a four by unit and c6 the caro-kann
defends d4 we have d5e captures C
captures and CC for now the panel attack
Knight to f6 we have a knight c3 e 690
to f3 Bishop to b4 by Karpov seek after
Sunday night capture Sun d5 and Bishop
to b2 and already you can see in the
position that Karpov pretty much
achieved what he always wants to achieve
Karpov has has created an isolated deep
on and he will try to capture it for the
rest of the game that's how carpal rolls
ix to c6 we have Bishop to d3 and now
Bishop back three seven adding more
protection to the g5 square so he can
freely castle so there won't be any age
495 ideas we have castles by unit and
castles by Karpov a3 now I'm not
allowing any of the Knights to jump to
before we have Knight captures on c3
Bishop captures on uncie three and now
Bishop to f6 Knight to e5 we have Knight
to e7 carpel now plans to play Knight to
d5 he's gonna blockaded be isolated to
deep on and then we'll figure out how to
capture it
Queen to f3
we have Knight to d5 and Bishop to e4 a5
now by karpov rook a to C 1 and b6
Bishop to d2 now not allowing the knight
to capture it bishop to b7 and we have a
clean 2g 3G 6 now and you know mind you
this is this is probably a blindfold
game but again I'm not completely sure I
will let you be the judge of that
Bishop to eight-six bipolar attacking
Corp of the rookin f8 Bishop to g7 but
should capture screen captures and
Knight to g4 now quick the b8 here
Karpov offers the exchange of Queens and
polgár declines this she plays Knight to
e5 and we have Knight to f6 now with a
double attack on the bishop on e4 Bishop
all the way back to be one Queen to d6
and this comes with an attack on the d4
pawn we into a for defending it and
Queen to d5 now Karpov is threatening
checkmate on g2 Pagar defense this would
F three rook 8 to see a by Karpov rook C
to D 1 we have Queen to b3 and Queen to
d2 group to c7 Karpov now is preparing
to double up on the C file and this is a
pretty much the critical moment in the
game here you displayed rook
dt 1 and this is a very important move
for this game this is the crucial move
for this game so remember you just
played rook D to e 1 here it goes rook
d2 d1 Karpov double up on the C file
rook F the c8 and here you did played
rook to e3 attacking Karpis Queen and
here comes one of the most mysterious
moves ever played in chess in this
position Anatoly Karpov world champion
Anatoly Karpov at that played Queen to
d1 yes that's exactly what he played he
played Queen to d1 and now you might you
might wonder what what just happened
here why did he play Queen to d1 well
Pagar probably also wondered that she
played rook captures on d1
Karpov played rope
c1 and here rook captures and c1 was
played rock captors and c1 and the Queen
captures and c1 and in this position a
former world champion Anatoly Karpov
resigned to the game so first time I saw
this I was like this this is just stupid
but then after after some investigation
probably this is a mindful game and what
actually happened here in this position
I to remember that move this rock to c7
by carpoon was played and here polgár
played rook D to e one what Karpov
thought polgár played was actually rook
F to e 1 and after rook F T 1 is played
Karpov actually continued to play this
game with DF Luke and he won not with
the Dirac anyone
so what Karpov actually thought he was
playing was rook F the c8 rook to e3 now
attacking the carpus Queen and now
Karpov when he played Queen to d1 he
thought he was actually grabbing the
rock can be one so Karpov thought he
played Queen captures rook on d1 even
though there was no rock on d1 because
Karpov didn't probably didn't hear rook
D - we want he he heard rook after you
want this is this is very disturbing so
he thought that after queen capture son
d1 now rook the c1 picks picks up the
Queen and it's all it's all good you
know it's it's a perfectly fine game for
black probably rook to e1 and after rook
captures rook captures it's a perfectly
fine position for black this is what
carpel was going for still head still
white has the isolated D pawn and the
carpel would probably go for something
like Knight to d5 and and create create
a game again against this isolated D
pawn but this never happened as after
this Rufus e7 Porto played Rock DT 1 and
after rook have to see it rook to e3
Karpov simply played Queen to d1 and
this is well for me this is one of the
the most disturbing moves I've ever seen
play played by a former world champion
so in case you you've seen this game or
you see this game so you don't get you
know confused what is this sorcery here
that karpova's is trying this is
probably a
likely explanation to what happened here
so I think that's it I think that it was
the blindfold section even though Karpov
won first place in the blindfold section
I think this is actually what happened
if any of you have any more information
about this game please do share in the
comments I will I will add any any
useful information in the description
below so yeah that's the video I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Patrick welter for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it and you know if you ever
play a blindfold game and you know miss
miss an idea or a piece don't feel too
bad about yourself because it can happen
to anyone even even world champions I
think all for watching and I will see
you soon